welcome to this video playing just kit
this is one of those guys we have a
terrible scoring against I don't
remember there was some history I think
I asked myself the same question when i
played in class now I really have to
check those games there must have been
something that that triggered this um
this memory echo III actually I'm did we
have this I remember something like that
what's that the line I think they go
before my anyway they are 94 is the
right move against this this line with a
three but it's not it's not that
well-known but he obviously has some
knowledge about this and went for went
for the line straightaway yeah came so
night it was Bishop d7
yeah it's obviously very equal very
equal ish yeah okay have to probably
look for some other line down that a
three line it is very this alone iam it
is very dangerous if black doesn't know
what he's doing but if he knows what
he's doing we get exactly this super
boring endgame check I mean I have a
very slight pool here very slight pool i
canna shaam ki can go on I can go on
this type of rank because I'm slightly
quicker here I've got no back rank issue
and so on this is actually not so
comfortable for black I get to see seven
and I came here said move I forgot about
that that's a good defense anyway
yeah I mean not much going on
okay check check check it's still not
much going on quite clearly a bit
I can still continue a little bit it's
not not exactly risking much time Boyce
maybe but I'm not behind in time mmm was
there anything that I can try I mean
chief g45 that doesn't does it help much
but yeah what can you do off the draw of
course I can offer a draw maybe he's
doing something check something weird on
hmm didn't expect King is six shouldn't
matter much check
mm there any way that I can try here I
guess not see we cannot even pose
problems that's it that's the issue
check simply nothing going on here check
check yeah check there is no absolutely
no way to play for William I mean if I
go up here give them the F pawn take a
seven that that looks rather risky let's
think about it briefly chat checks king
deform checking c5 look at four is seven
rook age form b6 route back by seven I'm
threatening that check though well maybe
I can do that I mean okay it's just a
blitzkrieg
yes to Jacob for okay well you can do a
great phone I'm sorry of course he can
go gay for it's not not totally crazy
time morning but it's not that clear now
I'm kind of I'm threatening rook c6f 6
this kind of thing check
Brooke a sixth XTX king d 7 King be five
Kings e7 hmm the stat we know not okay
six I don't know come on close
it's probably the wrong way I don't know
let let him let him figure it out
I think you can in fact if he lets me go
to the a pawn you can check okay to do
it check ok played the passive defense
said it's ok
check so winning or not check my winning
or not Jeep horn I've got no time good
absolutely no I'm here check now who's
on tonight against this guy chat like
working on house now totally winning I
screwed this totally equal end game up I
went too slow just too slow it's the
kind of hopeful nevaeh probably win all
the games in increments yes but anyway
yeah okay so it was just nothing
happening I have to ditch that opening
line and probably yeah yeah many people
still don't play 94 but 94 it looks kind
of strange but it is some it's a good
move yeah when right Ken white can take
here but black gets enormous
compensation after we should be six
there's really it's difficult to get
something here that a mia is a
relatively best but it's nothing they
are nothing to to count hope for much
check yeah king of eight and this is not
much happening at check check check
check check yeah jet not in touch good
to such a sad Rorschach the whole time
but here it's tougher gets interesting
check he had the trader so I couldn't
completely figure it out I thought this
was winning
and it is winning but he has f6 and can
draw interesting so this takes takes
King is 6 this is the thing he can this
is what I was talking about he can force
that that kind of situation so it was a
draw the Rue come the the book trade
Jack hey he avoided it and went for the
passive chat heads it's processed to the
drawer but not here of course yeah this
is just changing yeah I mean this is the
thing at some point they can just start
to play chess and then just play for the
clock and yeah it gave me that winning
endgame but I wasn't wasn't quick enough
wasn't quick enough at the end okay been
a long day probably shutting down this
session for now thanks for watching